When I was in Pavia I told myself over and
over again
that everything I had done since I
abandoned my son was for him to live
in a freer world
[Applause]
I can talk to you when we go
home we need people like you
[Music  ]
what am I going to do
I think I'm going to do you
came with me to fight for our
dreams
the Spanish woman suspects
what an aspiration is
[Applause]
[Music]
on a scale
amelia you don't know what danger you
're running into no matter the danger of
death
amelia garayoa
come on
I would like you to trust sense
[Music]
who are you the danger prevent the
person most suspected today the mind
of a German officer
that is to say that you wake up it is believed impossible
to understand I am the lover of a
man who represents what I hate the most
[Music  ] you
remember how beautiful and how easy
life was before
[Music] this
never brings you back